c'est l'heure du bilan aussi pour l'île
de porquerolles face au lavandou la plus
grande des trois îles du levant
sollicité par le tourisme international
envahie par des flots de vacanciers
porquerolles a voulu préserver ses
paysages gérer ses ressources à long
terme et développer les énergies de
remplacement
une attitude qui peut servir d'exemple
un reportage de florence schaal bravo
pour ce geste madame mais ici à
porquerolles on préférerait que vous ne
souhaitiez pas de sacs plastiques ils
risquent de dégrader la qualité des
produits agricoles de l'île
en effet les ordures ménagères ils sont
broyés et servent ensuite de compost
pour les cultures résultats fade des
charges polluantes et l'engrais de plus
économique qui soit c'est un des
exemples de l' équilibre écologique
recherché depuis que quatre cinquièmes
de porquerolles ont été placés par
l'état sous l'égide du parc national de
port-cros premier objectif préserver la
forêt menacée par le ce non pas avec de
larges tranches et artificielle mais
avec une remise en culture de terres
abandonnées culturel ya l'entretien de
la forêt c'était la leçon de nos
ancêtres
lorsque l'on m'a voulu se comporter en
gestionnaire intelligent il a réussi à
très bien
se satisfaire des conditions du milieu
et à ne pas entraîner des inondations
catastrophiques par contre à porter le
moment où ils oublient d'être
raisonnable il oublie la philosophie de
ces dieux on assiste à des catastrophes
et de la restauration de ces zones
dégradées
c'est quelque chose qui revient
certainement beaucoup plus cher que la
mise en place de méthodes de système de
gestion intelligente avec une subvention
annuelle d'un million cinq le
conservateur britannique s'emploie à
empêcher le processus de disparition des
plantes méditerranéennes des centaines
de variétés pourront ainsi renaître un
jour grâce à ses boutures et à ces
graisses objectifs à long terme du
conservatoire se suffire à lui-même en
produisant par exemple sept nouvelles
variétés d'abricots avec comme règle
d'or ne pas produire plus que les
besoins réels des habitants ni plus
surtout qu'on ne peut irriguer en effet
porquerolles manque d'eau mais refuse de
la faire venir à grands frais du
continent pour l'irrigation se sont
toutes les eaux usées qui au lieu d'être
rejetés à la mer sont recyclés dans
cette station d'épuration exemplaires
six scènes de vous activer et vous sont
réutilisés en engrais et lagunage
quitterait une zone humide la
municipalité à participer financièrement
à l'opération
comme elle a conçu un système de gestion
autonome et bénéficiaires de l'eau douce
mais se suffire à soi même cela ne
veut-il pas dire aussi refusé les autres
une certaine autonomie pourrait se
profiler à l'horizon
non c'est pas le problème il est pur
cours les l'ont bien compris mais de
toute façon nous sommes obligés de
passer par un certain nombre de
contraintes si nous ne voulons pas
rencontré de difficultés dans les années
à venir
l'urbanisation s'est exclu il ya un
potentiel qui existe un nom sur l'île de
porto ne voulant développer
l'urbanisation s'est aussi privé pour
corolle
en haut un choix écologique
malheureusement a sorti chez les
porquerollais d'un rejet certains des
étrangers que l'on considère ici comme
des pollueurs
les cinq cent mille visiteurs annuels
sont à peine tolérés exemple le port
sans commodités toulon parc fort cher
leur bateau
l'écologie doit encore prouver que c'est
bien fait ne sont pas réservé à
quelques-uns